que d'une parano quand elle se fait
arrêter par les flics mais c'est parce
que je m'appelle Nora Hamza oui c'est ça
oui bonsoir
alors vous êtes plus Maurice dans tout
le monde parle depuis 2 ans on vous a
découvert dans le biffor avant que vous
ne deveniez chroniqueuse au Grand
Journal et vous êtes également sur la
scène du République à Paris pour votre
spectacle éponyme et vous êtes ici ce
soir pour expliquer à tout le monde ce
que veut dire éponyme
exprès pour ça vous voulez que je fasse
le pitch de mon spectacle
c'est non c'est pas bien les pitch je
trouve pour le spectacle c'est une
humeur c'est l'humeur qui a tout gâché
en fait excusez-moi j'ai conscience
d'être très très bonne en promo
alors il y a ça il y a le Grand Journal
chroniqueuse au grand journal c'est un
peu comme Miss météo mais sans les seins
quoi c'est ça non bah c'est un peu ça
c'est un peu Miss Météo sans physique
quoi
ça se passe bien ouais ça se passe bien
avec vous ils sont adorables non la plus
chiante c'est moi je stresse beaucoup de
choses très sympa vous êtes d'origine
syrienne ça vous faire chaud au cœur de
voir en ce moment tous ces jeunes
Français qui veulent découvrir le pays
de vos parents non ce qui me fait chaud
au cœur c'est tous ces gens qui savent
maintenant ce que c'est que la Syrie
parce que avant c'était un petit peu
obscur un peu en fait vous êtes pas très
typé
non mais ça je me moque de ça parce que
ça veut aussi un peu rien dire quoi
c'est vrai que oui on m'a souvent dit ah
c'est marrant ça se voit pas mais en
même temps je sais pas à quoi les gens
s'attendent
vous dites je fais partie de ces arabes
qui ne se voit pas ouais parce qu'en
fait je me souviens d'un premier
entretien d'embauche il y a longtemps où
j'étais arrivé sans mettre la photo sur
mon CV et l'ananas a été super étonnée
en fait elle m'a été là je m'attendais
sur une beurette agressive mais quelle
bonne surprise qu'en fait il faut être
plus parisienne névrosé qu'arabe en tout
cas je suis parisienne névrosée
pas de Louboutin pendant 40 jours non
alors vous avez eu un début de carrière
très étonnant parce qu'en même temps que
vous études aux Celsa vous jouez votre
spectacle dans des pips chauds de
Pigalle devant 5 personnes non assez
faux
enfin non parce que j'ai jamais joué
dans sa vie j'ai joué dans d'anciens
pipe chaud qui était reconverti
reconverti en café théâtre mais j'allais
pas faire des sketchs genre des pipes
choses sur internet
je me demandais
c'était vous le fait de vous voir à poil
en fait
vous trouvez toujours un peu gros ça
mais alors pourquoi vous faites un
spectacle et pas un régime
c'est un conseil
[Applaudissements]
arrêtez de dire ça soyez fier de vous
c'est votre année chaque année vous
montez d'un cran je vois que vous venez
ici vous avez franchi une nouvelle étape
même bachar el chercher a besoin on vous
féliciter non il vous a pas appelé
vous continuez à vous payer tous vos
fantasmes avec tout l'argent que vous
gagnez à Canal bon c'est pas non plus
cette question elle pouvait que amener à
quelque chose comprenez pas cette
histoire
à poil mais dites-moi on va y aller
Jean-Luc et moi ce sont des traiteurs ça
c'est la soirée du Fooding et ce sont
des traiteurs qui cuisinent nu mais moi
je suis tombé à côté d'eux c'est pas du
tout
ce que vous avez trouvé pour défendre
comme des skis quoi finalement on est à
Paris
cette photo chaque fois vous viendrez
dans cette émission dans les 10
prochaines années vous aurez cette photo
dites-le vous bon attention le succès de
façon rend parano on va faire une
interview par un autre
[Musique]
alors quel compliment vous rend parano
de dire en vrai tu es moche
quelle phrase ne faut-il pas dire au lit
à une parano je préfère faire l'amour
dans le noir
que dit une parano quand il pleut ah bah
comme par hasard puis le jour où je me
suis dit
quelle est la question préférée de la
parano elle est à vous la valise
que dit une parano quand elle se fait
larguer de toute façon depuis le début
tu voulais me faire souffrir alors
que dit une parano quand elle croise un
SDF
tout ça pour me faire culpabiliser
que d'une parano quand elle se fait
arrêter par les flics
[Applaudissements]
que je dis une parano quand elle est
invitée
à mon avis il veut mon corps
[Rires]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater
un pouce bleu